we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P I think this is the
friendly this is a voicemail that is
praising me I don't think we've ever had
a voicemail with this much praise that
needed this many bleeps we've gotten a
lot of hate messages that need bleeps
but never praise that needs this many
bleeps take a listen to this
uh hey David this is uh Lamaze I've been
listening for a little minute now yeah
I'm from Philly so a little minute just
means a long period of time yeah I don't
know why we do that but that's just
something we do anyway I just wanted to
say I think you actually doing great
you're doing God's word for real for
real if I was to tell you the truth like
I think you out here doing God's work
but I what I don't like about the show
and this is not a knock on you at all
it's been here white people that come in
calling saying she's not even watching
all of your content like you can tell
that they don't watch it and they just
wanted to call to harass you like at
least I'm calling the harass you
uplifting you I'm not you know calling
to just harass you to be like oh
of you that that's weird like but anyway
I think the show was great I think
you're doing a phenomenal job and I want
you to keep it up buddy all right thank
you have a good one well I appreciate
the praise really putting uh Pat to work
there making this radio and FCC friendly
for our radio broadcast here is what I
would say about this I agree completely
that there is something really sad and
depressing about people who spend so
much time writing me these long hate
emails or leaving me these long hate
voicemails not only in reaction to
things I've said but barely paying
attention to things that I've actually
said and as you know we have a lot of
different trolls and people who call in
and they attack me for things I have not
actually said and what I go back to is I
actually feel bad for them you know
sometimes I'll get one of these messages
and I'll go oh that really bothers me
and then I'll say wait a second
how sad of a life must someone have that
they go hey you know what I think I'm
gonna get my phone out and leave three
three-minute voicemails swearing and
making a fool out of myself for someone
I don't even know and I realize they
must lead truly sad and depressing lives
and I end up feeling bad for them and I
think uh the caller makes that point
very very well we have a great bonus
show for you today we are going to talk
about a video that appears to show
another one of these people trying to
pass bills against drag dressed in drag
this one is from Texas the last one was
from Tennessee this one's from Texas
secondly Kerry Lake not Nikki Haley won
the CPAC vice presidential poll topping
Ron DeSantis topping Nikki Haley it is
another sign that CPAC is still full
Maga and then thirdly former Maryland
Republican Governor Larry Hogan says he
will not be challenging Donald Trump in
the 2024 primary fine not a big deal but
his reasons as to why are super super
interesting sign up at joinpakman.com to
get access to those discussions on the
bonus show you can use the coupon code
24 starts now all one word all lower
case this is the best way you can
support the work we do join pacman.com
coupon code 24 starts now remember
make your voice heard for free
by making sure you're subscribed to our
YouTube channel at youtube.com the
davidpackman show like our videos leave
a comment and also don't forget that
much of our content now available in
Spanish at davidpackman.com Spanish see
you on the bonus show it's just the
beginning of a great week of programs
for you